thank you alejandro yes i'm here with uh
leveronian
after let's say uh an uneventful uh game
uh lev
how do you feel about the game first of
all uh
yeah i i know this line it's uh it is
visually
more pleasant for white and uh you have
to play precisely with black
i'm not sure i managed to play the most
precise moves uh because
maybe you can show us where you think
yeah um
yeah i thought i thought that maybe it's
a bit unpleasant for me during the game
i thought that this is nothing
and then i kind of felt that maybe you
know he just pushes because if i play
something like 23
white can always take and play rook f1
then he still uh continues uh to push
the pawns on
i mean shouldn't be a big deal of course
he cannot take this pawn
probably yes because of g5 g5 and then
f4 yes
and then it's uh probably fisher bishop
right
maybe even king's two first to drop the
questions back yep
uh so i'm not so sure maybe probably
it's nothing
anyway i mean uh uh but but
i understand wesley's
approach he's you know white's position
is visually pleasant to play and he's
not risking much so he wanted to push
and and i think uh what happened is
uh he thought that he can play quincy
three but then knight d5
and i'm in total control so because of
he takes e5 you don't take the knight
because then you drop the rook but you
play oops
but you play queen five for queen g6 but
you just play
with m5 yes and then
black can only be better because the
queen on g5
is controlling the squares and this c6
weakness in this line for example is not
really a big deal so
i thought that it's you know rook the
six or anything
uh the bishop is very powerful it seems
like yes yes
the position is opening up white's
knight doesn't have squares
so i wasn't sure if it's better for me
but i wasn't
i was totally sure that it cannot be
worse and after 95 can he move the queen
somewhere and
just say that you have to be under
attack yes uh quincy two knight f6
and quincy four uh yeah f6 i thought
f6 is good enough yeah and the same now
if you take again just check right now
cd cd ah
got it yeah cool and uh after queen to
b3 after that everything kind of uh
simplified yeah i thought uh you know
uh maybe i can just try to place
some tricks but then objectively there's
nothing for me
how do you feel after the first two
rounds pretty solid two blacks two easy
draws
how do it's good it's a
good start of the tournament now i have
more weights to look forward to and
just to improve my play i mean
so far it's not not bad but it can be
better
a lot of things have changed in the past
year and a half for pretty much
everybody how does it feel to get back
to over-the-board chess and just touch
the pieces
feel the energy of your opponent how
does that feel
oh it's a great feeling because
this has been part of my life since i
was
nine years old and to have such a long
break is of course
you have this anxiety because
you stop dreaming about chess and
at some point you don't even understand
how you should train because
if you analyze a lot of openings
very solid openings you're not going to
succeed
in in a rapid format
but year and a half we only had rapid
chess
so it's so now i'm working like crazy
during this tournament
you have to catch up on the opening of
work that's an interesting insight
uh actually if i remember correctly
vichy anon mentioned that
just coming back to uh to this routine
of traveling and going to play
tournament
it just doesn't feel like his nature
anymore
do you have that problem any at all or
no not really i mean i but this is
something i was really missing i was
missing seeing
uh new cities and well
bucharest i love bucharest i share so
much
great memories and i generally romania
and bucharest these are
wonderful cities that don't have the the
pr
i mean it's such a beautiful city
bucharest but
i maybe i'm mistaken but i think the
romanian
people need to appreciate it more i need
to talk about it more and bring people
here to see this beautiful
villas of 18th 19th century
great architecture incredible well thank
you very much uh
lev a lot of good memories for you here
in bucharest
including one victory in 2019 in this
tournament
so uh it's great to have you back and
good luck in the rest of your games
guys back to you thank you